I said so I'll be back ready to play by
April time and he said no you need to
understand you might never ever play
football again and I've been being
perfectly honest reason young man you
need to understand that you might die
[Music]
my childhood was not ideal at all my dad
was in and out prison it was just me and
my brother looking out for each other
whether it was my mom going into
hospital at first I was too young to
even like understand what was going on
so I would always look to Joe to sort of
give me guidance unfortunately for my
mom at the time when she wouldn't have
known but by the time I was 8 she got
sectioned and put on a psychiatric unit
I would always like work together so
well so I had assumed that most brothers
like that but I think because of our
hardship we've actually become even more
close and we're like two minds like
thinking as one we made our way up to
Rochester and it's like Greater
Manchester to to stay with my auntie to
stop us from going into care
[Music]
they taught me so much as a player but
also as a man they gave me like the
foundations that they pride themselves
on as a club and from the age of nine up
until 15 it was I was Joe Thompson who
played for Manchester Knight
[Music]
but then I found myself if nothing and
my old teacher said why don't you go
down to Rochdale it's a stone's throw
away from your house I know you men
doesn't drive and you can walk to
training and I did that but I enjoyed it
I was free again I felt like I was able
to express myself I was performing and I
was better than the rest My partner my
wife Chantal was pregnant expecting our
first child Lula and I just felt like it
was time for a change I was feeling
strong I was feeling fit
I got a few men in the matches and
everything was rosy and then all of a
sudden out of nowhere just hit me like a
train some lunch popped up in my neck
and straight away the club doctor sent
me off to the specialist to go get a
biopsy I went to the hospital and spoke
to the professor and he gave me the
worst news that you could possibly give
anybody he said you've got cancer
you've got Hodgkin's lymphoma and it's a
cancer that attacks your immune system I
burst into tears and started crying and
yeah and those it's not a day that I
like to really relive what so they
thought out a large remember said to him
so right okay so six months and I've
pretty sure it was October 23rd I said
so I'll be back
ready to play by April time he said no
you need to understand you need to chalk
the season off you might never ever play
football again and I'm being perfectly
honest reason young man you need to
understand that you might die and I was
like
you're just gonna say it like that and
he was I I can not put it any other way
but there's obviously treatment and it
does cure lots of people and hopefully
with a bit of look you'll be okay
we used to dovetail but now obviously
when he's the one that's ill there's no
dovetailing so I knew they had to be on
me too to be that rock I just remember
thinking every message that comes is
filling up the glass bit more positivity
keeping you strong and football fans
from all over the world wrote to me and
messaged me and I can never thank them
enough for what they did for me support
yeah I just remember thinking I've got
an army behind me I'm ready to go to war
cancer or me it was only going one way I
was either gonna die I was gonna get
over it and live on for me physically
trying to get back into football it was
so so talk back at Rochdale I was
playing with my mates and I was enjoying
the banter in the changing rooms and it
was just yeah I was on top of the world
and I could also set my sights on
achieving again instead of surviving
settled at home you lose a bit older she
gone to school Chantal was doing well
with her businesses and things were
alright with my brother and my mum was
everything was cool
it just came out of nowhere I had a
routine scan that I needed to do which
was going on two and a half three years
just to pop in at the Christie's and
just double check that everything was
all right and then the professor just
said we just noticed a change from your
previous scan since you've been in
remission so we just want to do another
one to just double check and then I'm
Christmas Eve he told me the cancer had
come back I was angry I was very angry I
were I fought I've done everything I've
got over the first time and I've worked
so hard to get back to where I want it
to be and I was ready to kick on and try
and progress in the game I think you
could you could see there was something
up because he actually confided in
myself
and he said that the doctors have said
to him to play on as long as he can and
it come to like a loggerhead where he
was playing away to MK Dons and we
looked across at one of what were at
each other and I could see in his eyes
that he was done as such where he
couldn't carry on no more playing
football if it did everything right and
I gave it my all if the cancer beat in
me I could look my family and my friends
dead in the eye and say I didn't give up
I just got beaten so whichever way it
goes just know that I've given it my all
just remember walking out the hospital
doors and there was a little breeze and
a bit of rain and it came down and I was
like we're back we're back on track
we're living it wasn't long after he
camp came out I spoke to him on the
phone he was like I've had to learn how
to walk again with me the first thing I
needed to do was rebuild myself as a man
and then start to dream again of being a
footballer just thinking we need to get
ourselves out of this relegation fight
this relegation battle we had a chaplain
I think on the last day of the season it
gone down to the last game of the season
it was a straight shoot and watch
between walls and Oldham it was nil nil
and the gaffer gave me and Steven Davis
a nod to go on and I literally said he
said look we need a goal I said just
leave it with me and four minutes later
thankfully for me a good little nod down
from Calvin Andrews in the box I know it
was I had a bit of time and I shifted it
onto my right put it onto my left it
sees mice winger and I don't usually use
and I just remember thinking this is it
and time just stood still I put my foot
through the ball hit the back of the net
and it was just just it was amazing it
was like I was soaring through the sky
to a certain extent and I could still
see it all coming towards me the stand
but like there was a sea of blue coming
down and then it snapped back came I
noticed the noise and I think for
everyone at Rockdale and everyone
associated with Rochdale I'm pretty sure
they've not heard a noise like that at
the crown or Larina ever it was like
mass eruption of emotions not just
because of what the goal meant for the
football club but what it meant for JT
because that battle they'd undergone
four to three years of his life was put
to the puts it aside just for that
magical few moments and it was a special
beyond imagination going back into the
changing rooms after it
the boys are buzzing and we've done it
we survived and I think the ultimate
survivor to a certain extent I've made
sure that everyone that survived and we
maintain that Ligue 1 status
for me the book wasn't it's not about me
it's about you can do it if you put your
mind to it no matter the circumstances
and just keep believing and even when
times get tough just look inside and dig
deep and find out what motivates you and
what's going to drag you out of the hole
[Music]
you
[Music]